so the first thing I want to talk about
because I've never asked you this but I
was doing my research last night and I
didn't understand how how critical you
were in Warner Brothers getting the
rights to Harry Potter
so let's talk about this for a second
um what was it about that that said oh
we should get this you know what I mean
it was a great book and we read it in
galleys we it had not been published so
it was not
uh I think while we were negotiating it
was released in England and it started
becoming a phenomenon it was just a
great story and it was like it just felt
fresh and it just felt you know it
caught my imagination more than anything
else and then I met JK and she laid out
seven books like where it was going it
was like wow okay we don't have to do
much you know like it's been figured out
uh we just have to now figure out how to
reduce it to him
to our kind of experience you know
um
it was not a kind you know it was
interesting because at the time some of
my boss's reaction was why are you
buying a kid book for a lot of money and
I'm like it's not a kid book it's an
everybody book it's it's got a great
imagination that's what drought you know
that's what drew me to it yeah obviously
it turned out well yeah um do you think
that is of the because you were involved
in a lot of stuff at Warner Brothers
Matrix I can give you a laundry list of
stuff you were involved with do you
think the Harry Potter thing was the
biggest thing of your career in terms of
figuring out identifying something like
be before anyone else realized what it
was uh that in The Matrix
I think Matrix was harder in many
respects because it just doesn't
resemble storytelling that was being
going on so at least with Potter it was
like you know you go to a school you
have teachers there was a lot of
familiar aspects to it so those two in
very different ways you know obviously
financially Potter was an incredible
thing and thankfully they really managed
it really well
um and you know each movie I thought was
really good and and that's not easy to
do but she gave the blueprint Matrix was
harder because the blueprint was being
figured out sure uh you obviously along
the way have tried to make movies that
have not come together for whatever
reason if you could get the financing to
make anything you want what is that
project that you've been trying to push
up that hill that you couldn't have
somehow hasn't been made wow there's two
probably too many to pick one that uh
uh
I gotta think about that because that
that's
The One That Got Away you can come back
to it yeah let's come back to her let me
think about it because it's a good
question and I I just to narrow down to
one they're all my babies you know so
it's like sure yeah
um with this movie
um how when did you guys after bumblebee
I know you were developing two different
things after Bumblebee with or so I
heard how did you guys figure out that
this was going to be the sequel rather
than like a bumblebee sequel or and
maybe rather than something else
well what was interesting about the
experience of Bumblebee and it really
influenced this movie a lot was
the intimacy that we were able to create
emotionally the audience clearly left
but they were missing the spectacle
and so what we decided to do with this
movie was take that intimacy and put it
back into a spectacle so that's what
ended up being you know and also you do
bumblebee can't talk
so it does create some limitations on
how you could tell a story and we were
trying to find something that both had
character arcs for our humans but also
for robot
and
um I think that's one of the really
satisfying things if you're a fan of the
franchisor if you're not is
seeing Optimus Prime struggle with what
he believes in
you know and that experience of watching
his character Arc and Anthony's
character Arc Collide and like that
Collide thing you know and
there you go right for you
um you know I think that is the spine of
the movie sure you've now made a number
of Transformers films which one do you
think went through the most changes in
the editing room uh and why well
Michael's movies always go through a lot
of a lot of metamorphosis because
Michael likes to juggle so many things
so trying to put it all together uh can
be but emotionally
probably this movie
changed the most in the sense of how to
um
accentuate the character arcs against
the spectacle which was our objective
but that's a that is a nuanced thing to
go through so it takes a long time from
an editor editing point of view of like
do we have the right balance are we do
we not have enough motion do we have too
much action what is the what is that so
I wouldn't say that the story itself
fundamentally changed but I think the
balance of it changed all the way
through it did you end up with a lot of
deleted scenes in this one I never
remember yes there's a few uh actually
there's quite a few now that I think
about it um yes we did because we were
hell-bent on
keeping the narrative focused on the
emotional arcs going on and so even
though there were some really great fun
stuff that we had that we cut but we
also wanted it to be under two hours
that was an objective so so yeah some
some things got sacrificed along the way
obviously every time a Transformer is on
screen it costs real money so how does
it actually work in terms of figuring
out the budget in terms of like okay we
can get 45 minutes of Transformers
footage in in the movie and because of
costs like how does that get figured out
or is it sort of just like um you know
like let's just do the movie and then
we'll figure like can you take me
through like that the producer had if
you will I think the hardest part of for
a studio actually is to be flexible
about this because the idea that you can
plan out
what a battle scene is going to be you
know we do we budget we have a
guesstimate then you go shoot a scene in
a crater and you realize it's really big
and how do you keep the world alive
during through the process you know and
so Studio has to have a trust in the
filmmakers to a certain extent that that
in other movies they don't have to have
because
we're operating in a blank space and
like how are we approaching it you know
because all right in our minds is there
16 Transformers in that shot or two
um and so really it's a process that you
go through you do your best guesstimate
but it always changes but what we've
found is some areas get more expensive
and some areas get less and then you
always run into that moment where okay
you've run out of you know now we know
what's in here what do we have to
sacrifice to stay within the budget if
you have Optimus in a shot and then you
add say three other Transformers how
much does that amplify the VFX budget of
that shot and how much is it sort of
like you know what I mean like does it
matter if you have five robots in the
frame yes it does the the the thing that
people you're adding complexity when you
add complexity you're adding cost so the
ultimate battle scene here where you
have all those things going on is really
expensive
um and it's it's
what I've learned over time is there's a
way to do it where you
project yourself thinking about all
right how many do I need in this shot
and the longer the scale the more
expensive so
it helps storytelling sometimes to stay
localized on it you know the the battle
on the bridge
um
you're not seeing everything but you're
kind of peeking it but if you try to do
all that then you're gonna get out of it
so it's it's really fundamentally a
filmmaker
point of view about okay what is the key
element of the stories that I'm trying
to keep alive in this shot and
can I eliminate the things around you
we've spoke uh recently a little while
ago about the Transformers one which is
the
um uh ilm animated can't wait for this
thing uh so it's been like a month or
two since I last spoke uh any
developments how is it looking when will
people see footage yeah well I don't I
don't know about when we'll see it it'll
be a while
um
I'm I can't tell you how excited I'm
getting about it it's one of those
things that like it just keeps
progressing in the right direction you
know you never know sometimes when
you're making a movie or you're like
well I think it's working everything I'm
seeing is working and it's exceeding my
sense of what it was going to be so I'm
really excited about it it is a very
fresh and different look I would say
different than any animated movie you've
seen so which is a high bar to set but
ilm is capable of delivering it but also
it's the imagination of our artist and
our director
um and
you know one of the great things is as
you actually put the voices to the
characters you know when we first
listened to Chris Hemsworth's voice
they're like God is he going to be a
good Optimist you know you start
obviously he starts his Orion Pax and
you don't become optimists for a while
um so he's not playing
for most of the movie what we think of
as Optimist Peter Cullen so it's that
transition that that and Chris's voice
has a Timber that it it reminds it it's
logical that he you know that Peter
Collin would take over that voice if you
would which is really great for the fans
are going to really feel great but
Scarlett is amazing and it's just coming
alive in a way that um
it's really rewarding and I and it just
we had confidence in our director and
all he's doing is giving us more and
more